>> Harris: PRESIDENT BIDEN
WITH FRESH BACKLASH FROM
SANITIZED POLITICAL PROJECTION
AS I PUT IT THE VISIT TO THE
BORDER AND THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CROSSING IN THE
UNITED STATES NONE OF THEM HE
ACTUALLY SAW, I DON'T KNOW HOW
THAT'S POSSIBLE.
CONSTRUCTION WORK CONTINUES ON A
BARRIER SURROUNDING HIS DELAWARE
BEACH HOME, THAT'S NICE.
WHY?
FOR INCREASED SECURITY
OF COURSE.
AND IT WILL COST TAXPAYERS
$500,000, BRIAN?
>> Brian: SO IT'S AROUND THE
SIDE OF HIS HOUSE, IT WILL COST
$500,000 AGAINST TAXPAYERS
PICKING IT UP IT'S A BIG WHITE
WALL DAILY MAIL PICKED IT UP
TOOK A PICTURE IN ATTIC IT'S
IRONIC WHERE HE CONTINUES TO SAY
WALLS DON'T WORK.
HE PUSHES TO GET THE SHIPPING
CONTAINERS OFF THE BORDER COME
MAKESHIFT BARRIERS TO SLOW DOWN
WOULD BE ILLEGALS AND AT THE
SAME TIME WITH STATUS AS IT IS
HOUSE LIKE A BALL GAME.
>> Harris: LIKE THE
MINNESOTA VIKINGS?
THE PURPLE CURTAIN?
THAT WASN'T A WALL.
>> Brian: IT'S A EUPHEMISM.
>> Harris: WHO HAD THE
CURTAIN?
>> Brian: THAT WAS THE
STEELERS.
>> Harris: I KNEW SOMEONE HAD
A CURTAIN.
>> Brian: SAME YEAR, 1970s,
BEFORE YOU WERE BORN.
>> Harris: NOT EVEN TRUE, I
DON'T EVEN THINK NFL WAS AROUND
WHEN I WAS BORN.
EMILY THIS SPEAKS TO WHY THE
BORDER CZAR DOESN'T FEEL THE
EMINENCE OR URGENCY OF DISASTER
AT THE BORDER, SHE TOO LIVES IN
A STATE WITH A WALL.
>> Emily: YOU THOUGHT SHE
WOULD BE A PARTICIPANT OR
COMMENTED ON ACKNOWLEDGED BIDEN
HAVING HIS LAYER OVER THERE IN
EL PASO BEFORE HE WAS ON HIS WAY
TO THE SUMMIT IN MEXICO CITY.
FRANKLY IT'S ONE MORE INDICATION
THIS ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
ACTUALLY CARE.
THEY HAD TO HAVE A SANITIZED
VIEW OF EL PASO, THEY BOTCHED
STATISTICS BY THE WAY OUR
PRESIDENT DID WITH
PRESIDENT OBRADOR OF MEXICO WHEN
HE TRY TO TALK ABOUT FENTANYL,
HE IS NOT ACCURATELY BRIEF, HE
WAS IN A MANUFACTURED BUBBLE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME WHICH INCLUDES A
WALL AND RUBBER WHAT HE CALLED
TRUMP'S WALL, HE CALLED IT THE
PHYSICAL EMBODIMENT OF TRUMPS
INABILITY TO DEVELOP EFFECTIVE
IMMIGRATION POLICY AND YET WHEN
HE WENT DOWN TO EL PASO HE USED
THE FIRST IMAGE HE USED TO TOUT
THAT VISIT WAS A WALL.
SO WHY IS HE MAKING THAT
SYNONYMTHAT AS WE SEE THE WALL T
EL PASO SO YOU CAN LOOK INTO
JUAREZ EASILY AND SEE WHY THERE
IS AN ABSOLUTE LACK OF ANY
BARRIER.
THAT'S WHY EVERYONE DOWN THERE
BY THE WAY INTO JUAREZ IN
EL PASO IT'S A LINE, NOT A
BORDER IT'S A LINE.
>> Harris: THAT'S WHAT WE SAY
IN ARIZONA AND WE HAVE A
STRUCTURE.
BECAUSE THE FENTANYL IS FLOWING
AND THE MEN AND WOMEN ARE DOING
EVERY THING THEY CAN TO TRY TO
STOP IT.
SO, CARLY, HERE IS A QUESTION
BECAUSE GOVERNOR ABBOTT OPEN MY
EYES TO THIS YESTERDAY.
PART OF THE CLEANED UP OPTICS
WERE PROVIDED BY TEXAS TAXPAYERS
BECAUSE JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO HE PUT THOSE CONTAINERS IN
PLACE AND THAT STEM THE TIDE.
THEN THE PRESIDENT WANTED THEM
REMOVED.
BEFORE IN ARIZONA.
>> Harris: BUT HE WAITED UNTIL
THE TIDE HAD BEEN STEMMED AND
THEN HE GOES DOWN THERE AND THEN
SUDDENLY HE CAN SEE YOU KNOW
MAYBE A WALL.
HE DID THE SAME THING IN NUMA
ARIZONA WHERE THE DEMOCRAT MAYOR
THERE SAID WE ARE IN TROUBLE.
HERE IS A LITTLE MONEY FOR
BUILDING OUT SOME STRUCTURE.
I MEAN THIS IS A PIECEMEAL AND
ITS POLITICAL.
>> Carley: EXACTLY, IT IS A
LOT OF THOUGHTS OPTICS AND
POLITICKING HAPPEN RIGHT NOW AND
THE POLITICAL ELEMENTS OF THIS
WHEN HE WAS A SENATOR IN 2006
WHICH APPROPRIATED MONEY FOR 70.
HE ALSO VOTED IN FAVOR NO, HE
ALSO SUPPORTED JAILING EMPLOYERS
WHO HIRE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
SAID SANCTUARY CITIES SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO VIOLATE FEDERAL
LAW.
HE SAID A FENCE WAS NEEDED TO
STOP DRUGS COMING IN FROM
CORRUPT MEXICO.
SO, 17 YEARS AGO PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
THE SAME IN THIS ISSUE.
IMAGINE THAT.
FLASH FORWARD TO TODAY, HE IS IN
MEXICO TALKING TO LOPEZ OVER OBR
WITH A GOOD CHANCE OF STEMMING
THE FLOW OF DRUGS, WE HAD A
GREAT GUEST FORMER D.A. SPECIAL
OPERATIONS DIRECTOR WHO USED TO
LEAD OPERATIONS TARGETING
MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS AND HE SAID
YOU COULD FIX THIS ISSUE, SECURE
THE BORDER, MUST PUSH MEXICO TO
SHUT DOWN THE CHEMICAL WEAPON
PRODUCTION LABS AND START
DEMANDING EXTRADITION OF
KINGPINS BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES LIKE EL CHAPO'S
SON.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
PRESIDENT MEXICO THEIR BIGGEST
FEAR IS PRESENT IN THE
UNITED STATES UNITED STATES.
>> Harris: DECLARE THEM AS
TERRORIST AS PRESIDENT ABBOTT
WANTS.
I FIND IT FASCINATING YOU DREW A
PICTURE OF BIDEN BACK IN THE
DAY.
I DON'T THINK YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
PERSON.
>> Carley: EXACTLY.
>> Harris: OR MAYBE THAT
PERSON WOULDN'T RECOGNIZE HIM
TODAY.
>> Martha: I THINK HE WAS TO
GET BACK TO THAT PERSON I SEE
HIM MAKING MOVES RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE HE SEES THE 2020 PORK
ELECTION COMING UP.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT WE HAVE
SPENT BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON THIS OMNIBUS BILL TO
MAKE SURE THERE ARE SECURE
BORDERS FOR UKRAINE AND ISRAEL
AND AROUND YOUR BIDEN'S HOUSE.
BUT FOR SOME REASON THIS ONE IS
A PROBLEM FOR HIM.
HE IS WALKING ALONG THAT WALL I
THINK FOR A REASON BECAUSE I
THINK HE WILL START WALKING BACK
THIS OBVIOUSLY THERE IS NOTHING
YOU CAN DO.
>> Harris: TO A CENTRIST
POSITION?
>> Martha: NOTHING TO DO BUT
HAVE A SECURE BORDER.
>> Harris: MARSHA BLACKBURN,
TESSIE SENATOR TOOK A DELEGATION
OF ALL WOMEN TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, SHE WAS IN EAGLE
PASS THE DEL RIO SECTOR WHICH
WE KNOW HAS HAD HUMAN
CATASTROPHE WITH PEOPLE OF ALL
AGES IN THE RIO GRANDE TRYING TO
GET HERE.
SHE WAS ON THE FAULKNER FOCUS
LAST HOUR TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER CRISIS AND BROUGHT UP
INTERESTING POINTS, WATCH.
>> YOU LOOK AT THE WOMEN AND THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE IN THESE
GROUPS, IT IS HARD STOMACH
HEARTBREAKING.
TO HUMANITARIAN CRISIS DOESN'T
STAY ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE DRUGS, THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, THE GANGS, THE
SEX TRAFFICKING, THE CRIME IN
OUR CITIES, THE DRUGS THAT ARE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES, IT IS
CAUSING A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS IN
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Harris: MARTHA?
>> Martha: MARSHA BLACKBURN IS
MAKING A GREAT POINT.
THE UNTOLD STORY THAT NEEDS TO
HAVE A LOT MORE ATTENTION I
THINK FOR A LONG TIME IS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE DEDICATING
THEIR ENTIRE LIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY TO STOPPING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THAT IS GOING ON
DOWN THERE.
THESE YOUNG GIRLS WERE TOLD
BASICALLY IF YOUR FAMILY PAYS
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY WE WILL GET
YOU A JOB IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY GET HERE AND THEY ARE BEING
ESSENTIALLY.
THEY HAVE NO AGENCY WHATSOEVER
SO I GIVE SENATOR BLACKBURN A
LOT OF CREDIT AND IT'S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T SEE IN IT'S NOT
TIME TO HAVE YOUR EYES OPEN AND
SAY LET'S GO LIKE WE SAID
YESTERDAY, JUST DROP ME IN THERE
AND DON'T TELL ANYONE I'M COMING
BECAUSE I WANT TO REALLY SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON HOW MANY POINTS
WHEN HE FOR TH